سررت بلقائك في مانيلا اليوم بلقائك لطيفًا للغاية ،
أنا متحمس جدًا لمقابلتك ،
أنت أحد لاعبي المفضل ، شكرًا
لك وأردت أن أسألك عن
بدايتك في دبي ، فلنبدأ من هناك نعم نعم
أه كيف كان ذلك رائعًا
أعني أنها المرة الثالثة التي أتيت فيها إلى
دبي ، كنت هنا من قبل للتدريب أو
لقضاء إجازة ، لكن المرة الأولى التي
ألعب فيها البطولة بالفعل شاهدنا
الملعب للمرة الأولى العام الماضي ،
انسحبنا بسبب الإصابة ، نعم كان من
المفترض أن
يأتي  قبل يومين من اللعب في
مرسيليا في فرنسا ، لقد
آذيت ظهري قليلاً ، لذلك اعتقدت
أنني لن أعطي نفسي
فرصًا جيدة للعب بشكل جيد هنا
والمنافسة هنا ، لذلك قررت الانسحاب
ولكن هذا العام "  أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة ، أشعر بصحة
جيدة ، لذا فأنا مستعد للذهاب ، نعم
أنت متحمس ، نعم ماذا عن الدوحة
قبل أن تكون هنا رائعة لأول مرة في
الدوحة أيضًا ، لذلك اعتقدت أن هذا العام
سيكون من الجيد القيام بنوع من الشرق الأوسط
نعم ، إنها المرة الأولى لك في
الشرق الأوسط بخلاف لقضاء إجازة كنت
تعرفها إلى دبي من قبل لقضاء
إجازة ، نعم ، نعم لقضاء إجازة
وتدريب قبل عامين أيضًا ، لكن
نعم ، تلعب الدوحة لأول مرة مع ألمانيا في
دبي لأول مرة.  من الجيد
بالنسبة لنا نحن اللاعبين الذين تعرفهم أن
لدينا هاتين البطولتين متتاليتين.
أهم المدن
أه في الشرق الأوسط ، لذا نعم بالطبع
أنت واحد من أكثر اللاعبين الواعدين
ويتحدث الناس دائمًا عن متى سيحصل
فيليكس على أول جراند
سلام ، هل تشعر بهذا النوع من الضغط
نعم
ولكن هذا ضغط  نعم ، أنا
بخير لأنني لست الشخص الوحيد في هذا
الموقف ، فهناك عدد قليل من اللاعبين منا
الذين أعتقد أنهم واعدون
ولديهم الطموح نفسه للفوز
ببطولة كبرى ، لذلك أشعر أن
طموحاتي  ترتبط الأهداف
أيضًا بالتوقعات من الخارج
في عالم التنس ، لذلك أشعر أنني
أتعامل بشكل جيد وأعيش على ما يرام مع
ذلك داخليًا ، نعم داخليًا ، إنه
ضغط جيد ، وكأنه
يحفزني ، نعم ، إنه يحفزني
يبقيني أه يبقيني على أهبة الاستعداد
ويبقيني على استعداد تام كل
أسبوع أشعر بأن كل مباراة
مهمة بالطبع وكل ما أفعله
له أهمية كبيرة لأنني
أشعر أنك تعرف كل يوم كما
أعتقد  أنت تعرف أي
اتصال أو ما يشبه ذلك
بالنسبة لي للوصول إلى هذا الهدف النهائي
عندما نتحدث عن ضغط الضغط صعب
جدًا بالنسبة لكم يا رفاق ورأيت فيلم
Netflix الوثائقي الذي تم
عرضه في نقطة توقف
أم ما هو شعورك عند المشاهدة  أنت نفسك
من الخارج خاصة أثناء
البطولة وكل ما لا أحبه
كثيرًا ، لا أحب أن تعرفه ، قل لي
أنني شاهدت الفيلم
الوثائقي على Netflix أيضًا ، لكن
ليس من المفضل أن أشاهده
أنت تعرف نفسي  دعنا نقول تحدث أو
أشاهد نفسي ألعب ولكن هذا
مهم لأن هذه هي الطريقة التي تعرف بها
إه ردود الفعل المناسبة آه هذا ما
كنت تفعله وهذا هو ما
تتعلمه من أخطائك وهذه هي الطريقة التي
تتحسن بها لذا أحيانًا مشاهدة
المباريات على سبيل المثال  لقد خسرت حيث
أريد أن أعيش تلك المباراة من جديد
وبالطبع كما لو لعبت بشكل سيئ وأريد فقط أن
أنسى الأمر ، لكن من
المهم أن أبذل الجهد وحاول
الجلوس ومشاهدته بالفعل
ومحاولة التعلم  من بين
أخطائك وما يمكنك القيام به بشكل
أفضل ، نعم ، الأمر مع دينيس ،
إنه أمر صعب للغاية ، ليس فقط
جسديًا وعقليًا أيضًا ، وقد رأينا
أنه كان واضحًا جدًا في
الفيلم الوثائقي ، أعتقد أنه أكثر مثل
أه أقصد  إنها رياضة بدنية أولاً
نعم ولكن عقليًا بعد
الانتهاء من المباراة ، يكون الأمر مستنزفًا تمامًا مثل
نعم لأنه دائمًا ما تعلم أن
لديك 20 ثانية أو ما شابه
لفك الضغط مثل
الاسترخاء بين نقطة ثم يكون
دائمًا  مثل
التركيز مرة أخرى وإعادة التركيز ، وبعد ذلك يكون الأمر
دائمًا مثل تشغيل مفتاح التركيز
وإيقافه ، وأشعر أن هذا
سيؤثر عليك عقليًا وبعد
المباراة تشعر بالتعب
ولا تريد التفكير في وجود
لحظة  قبل أن تخرجوا يا رفاق ، أه إلى
الملعب حيث تقفان كلاكما
وتريدان تجنب بعضكما البعض على الرغم من أنكما
تعرفان بعضكما البعض لا تقل
مرحباً أو أي شيء من السيف ، نعم نقول قبل
ساعات من أن نقول مرحباً عندما نرى
كل منهما  أخرى لأول مرة في اليوم
ولكن نعم ، نرى بعضنا البعض في غرفة خلع الملابس ،
ولكن بمجرد أن تعرف
الدقيقتين قبل الخروج ، فهذا هو الوقت الذي
تعرف فيه حقًا قفل المنطقة والدخول إليها
لأننا
نوعًا منا  أشخاص مختلفون في
الخارج ونحن في الملعب
بالطبع عندما تذهب إلى الملعب يبدو
الأمر أشبه
بممثل يذهب ويلعب في الفيلم
وكأنك
تذهب مع نوع مختلف من  الطاقة
والروح التي تحتاجها فقط لتكون
منافسًا شرسًا مثلك لا يمكن أن تشعر
بالاسترخاء مثلما أتحدث إليك الآن ،
يجب أن تكون أكثر حدة
ومثلًا لذلك هذا هو السبب في أن الدقائق التي تسبقنا
لا ننظر إليها  بعضنا البعض لا نقول أكاذيب
يحبسها الجميع ، إنه أمر
مثير للاهتمام إذا أعادتك إلى
الجزء العقلي ، هل لديك أي نصيحة
لنا ، أعني عندما أشاهدك أثناء
المباراة ، فأنا أحب كيف يمكنه فعل ذلك كيف
يمكنك ذلك  قم بذلك
من الخارج ، يكون الأمر أكثر إرهاقًا
في بعض الأحيان ، خاصةً عندما
تلعب دورًا مثل الماعز حيث
يطلق الناس أسماءهم وأشياء من هذا القبيل ، نعم ،
لا توجد وصفة سرية تستغرق وقتًا
كما تعلم لأنني أتذكر  في
المرة الأولى التي ألعب فيها الدمية ، أعني أنها كانت
صعبة لأنني أعني أنني شعرت وكأنني أه حتى
لو كنت عادة تدعم نفسك دائمًا
ولديك هذا الاعتقاد الذاتي جيدًا كما لو
كنت في الملعب ، فهو واحد ضد واحد
وأنت تشعر بأنني أستطيع الفوز
عندما  لعبت لأول مرة في بلدي
لم أشعر أنني أستطيع الفوز حقًا كما
تعلم ، ولكن بعد ذلك في آخر مرتين
لعبنا فيها شعرت أنني بخير ،
يمكنني حقًا على مر السنين
اكتساب هذه الثقة مثل ضد
أي شخص عندما أخطو  في الملعب ،
يجب أن أؤمن بنفسي حتى لو كان هو
المفضل حتى لو كنت ألعب ، حسنًا ،
إنه شيء يجب عليك العمل عليه ،
نعم ، شيء تعمل عليه بالطبع ،
أعني أن هناك أشياء لا
مفر منها كما تحتاج إلى  تتحسن
فيما تفعله بهذا الشكل ، هذا ما
نمارسه يتحسن فيما
نفعله ، وبعد ذلك بمجرد أن تبدأ في الشعور وكأنك
تتقن ما
تفعله بشكل أفضل ، يصبح من الأسهل
أن تتمتع بتلك الثقة بالنفس لأنك
تشعر وكأنك مسيطر
ومن ثم تعرف أنك تبدأ في الفوز
بمزيد من المباريات ثم في النهاية بعد
عامين تحصل حقًا على المزيد
والمزيد من تلك الثقة ولكن
هناك أيضًا جزء في بعض الأحيان يكون هناك
عمل يجب القيام به خارج الملعب
كما لو كنت خارج ملعب تدريبي
في بعض الأحيان ، كنت أفكر فقط في التحدث مع
أشخاص مقربين من عائلتك ومدربي
وأكون على ما يرام كيف يمكنني أن
أكون أقوى وأقوى عقليًا نعم بالطبع
وقرأت أنك قلت إنك لا
تتذكر يومًا في  حياتك دون أن
تتورط في التنس أنك في الواقع
هو الشيء الوحيد الذي تتذكره مثلما
كنت تفكر فيه كل يوم ، حسنًا ، دعنا
نقول أننا أخذنا التنس من حياتك ، ما هو
المسار الوظيفي الآخر الذي قد تسلكه ،
نعم ، سألت نفسي ذلك
أحيانًا ولكن بعد ذلك  أنا أيضًا كما لو كنت
محظوظًا لأنني وجدت هذا الشغف مبكرًا وأنا
مثل أنني ثابرت فيه
ولا أريدك أن تبقى في التنس ،
كما تعلمون ، أحب ما أفعله هو أنني
أريد أن أبقى  بالنسبة لي لأحب أن
أقوم بشيء آخر
لأنه صحيح كما قلت إنه
كان دائمًا جزءًا من حياتي ولكني سألت
نفسي بسؤال ولا أعرف أن
هناك أشياء كثيرة مثل
الآن لقد أتيحت لي الفرصة لمقابلة مختلف
الناس ومثل أشعر أن هناك
الكثير من الأشياء المثيرة للاهتمام للقيام بها وأشعر
أنني من النوع
الذي
أتحدث معه وأنك تعلم أنهم
متحمسون لما
يفعلونه ، أشعر وكأنني  أحب التحدث
مع الأشخاص الذين يحبونهم يعرفون ما يفعلونه ،
نعم أشعر أنني يمكن أن أجد أيضًا
اهتمامًا بما يفعلونه
إذا كنت في دراسات أو كنت في
رياضة أخرى أو أحب الفن أو أي شيء
أشعر به ، نعم  سأبذل
قصارى جهدي حقًا وأحاول أن أفعل ذلك بأفضل ما يمكنني ، لذا فقد
يكون هناك الكثير من الأشياء التي
لا أعرفها على أي حال البقاء في التنس
نعم ونتمنى لك كل التوفيق فيليكس ،
شكرًا جزيلاً على وقتك أيها
الأجنبي.